la crisis política y social en Perú
continúa sumando episodios la fiscalía
informó que abrirá 11 investigaciones
por la muerte de los alrededor de 60
ciudadanos fallecidos durante las
protestas iniciadas en diciembre de 2022
y garantizó que serán con estricto
respeto a las leyes y la defensa de
Derechos Humanos
esto responde al pedido de los
ciudadanos que denunciaron en excesos en
represiones policiales
hay diversas delegaciones que han sido
hostigadas por la policía y también han
sido detenidas no dio presencia de
fiscal ha habido una serie de
violaciones a los protocolos y
reglamentos e incluso ahora Ustedes han
podido apreciar que están violando el
ejercicio de la libre digamos protesta
la libre manifestación y tampoco han
permitido el ingreso de abogado recién
han ingresado algunos las tensiones
diplomáticas también rondan el gobierno
retiró definitivamente a su embajador en
Honduras por desconocer al gobierno de
Dina boluarte en tanto que el congreso
peruano declaró personas no grata a Evo
Morales y el expresidente boliviano
ratificó su postura
los ataques de congresistas que
justifican la represión Sangrienta
contra su pueblo con tal de aferrarse al
poder nos confirman que estamos en el
lado correcto de la historia no nos
cansaremos de denunciar las graves
violaciones de Derechos Humanos que
sufren nuestros Hermanos peruanos
mientras continúan los enfrentamientos
entre la policía y manifestantes en
contra de la administración de boluarte
e incluso grupos de izquierda
presentaron una moción de censura será
presidenta la salida de la crisis
peruana aún no está Clara Ni esa emisora
pronto